[Musique]
dossier de ce journal l'aménagement de
la défense ce quartier d'affaires de
l'ouest va connaître d'ici la fin de
l'année un certain nombre d'opérations
immobilières
il s'agira tout d'abord d'achever le
site en construisant de nouvelles tours
et pour cela une consultation
d'architectes sera lancée la semaine
prochaine elle durera deux mois et
travaux devront être fini à la fin de
l'année prochaine notre parfum 80 sera
ouvert un centre commercial au sein
duquel sera créé une école de danse
dirigée par carolyn carlson la défense
revit depuis 18 mois la raréfaction des
bureaux dans la capitale a redonné du
tonus au manhattan parisien les projets
d'aménagement du quartier sont ressorti
des cartons première réalisation
envisager la construction d'un immeuble
à l'extrémité ouest du site cette tête
de la défense a déjà suscité de très
nombreux projets dont le plus grandiose
que celui d'emile ayo il s'agissait de
deux immeubles miroir qui fermait la
perspective de l'arc de triomphe une
nouvelle consultation d'architectes va
être lancée pour cet immeuble avec comme
impératif conserver la perspective ces
immeubles ne devront en aucun cas être
vu dans la perspective des champs
elysées ce qui nous a mis amené à
définir un épais nuage très précis une
limitation de hauteur à 35 me la
deuxième idée importantes auxquelles
nous demandons aux architectes de
réfléchir c'est plutôt que de faire un
un immeuble ponctuelles monumental arts
au terme de cette perspective
d'organiser l'ensemble des immeubles de
tête défense autour d'une place c'est à
dire de créer un lieu public très
maîtrisé très dessinées et de très
grande qualité autour duquel viendra se
développer le programme de construction
dans deux mois on connaîtra le projet
retenu la construction pourrait
commencer fin 80 parmi les futurs
occupants un ministère celui de
l'industrie ou bien celui de
l'environnement
autre innovation pour la défense un
centre commercial le plus grand de
france avec 100 mille mètres carrés de
surface de vente et 6300 places de
parking en sous sol
coût de l'investissement rien que pour
le gros-oeuvre 750 millions deux grands
magasins occuperont à eux seuls vingt
mille mètres carrés mais les promoteurs
n'ont pas d'inquiétude pour louer le
reste il y as autour d'un million deux
cent mille habitants c'est une des plus
belles zones de clientèle du monde et
les commerçants ne s'y trompent pas et
ils viennent ils sont en train de signer
et nous aurons d'ici deux mois
bloquer l'ensemble des surfaces grandes
et moyennes et qui permettent justement
de structure et se sentent sur le plan
commercial
ce centre commercial sera aussi un
centre culturel avec neuf salles de
cinéma un centre de jazz et une très
grande patinoire qui pourra se
transformer en salle de spectacles
notamment pour ceux de l'école de danse
de carolyn carlson obligés de quitter
l'opéra
les élèves de la danseuse américaine se
sont en effet vus offrir 500 m² par les
promoteurs du centre
je viendrai de temps en temps pour
donner des cours et voir ce que font les
élèves mais la direction effective sera
assumée par caroline marcadé d'une
petite s'il demandait tour feront de
l'improvisation et montrons leur propre
création
et
dès le 10 mai carolyn carlson et ses
élèves donneront des représentations en
plein centre de la défense
karine carson pensez vous que la défense
soit un site adapté à la dance your
thing that la défense là un si bel
emplacement c'est une chance de
s'installer
[Musique]